Kristin Davis why Karsten good to see
you again you guys although under
circumstances probably not the greatest
in the world for you when you are on the
bounty hunter nothing like you are right
you mean because dogs a little heavy and
richer a little way yeah the jewelry
yeah kind of stupid face right there
dealing with people bail people and some
of that nature right the dog try to do
radio with breakfast still in his mouth
only if it stirs may correct gum welcome
Chris well hi Kristen we haven't seen
you in a long were you and Jeff were I
was 18 months federal confinement [ __ ]
its federal confinement different from
jailers that just you're being specific
I'm being specific it's a combination of
camps medium security Institute and
halfway house 11 and worse totally like
a max I don't think I'll ever get think
we're [ __ ] like Pappy Mason and those
[ __ ] big drug dealers aren't you like
did you go to Leavenworth no she didn't
one reason he knew so wait let me talk
to you was right before you went in yeah
and you remember you I had nice nails
then also very good well you've always
been very sexy I mean you know what is
medium security prison-- like in the
sense that like you know some people
will describe like how it's probably one
of those Country Club prisons I'm sure
it's not a country club those don't
exist anymore
tell me those articles came out they
like did away with them right medium is
where you're on confinement for
basically 24 hours a day and you have
ten minutes each hour in which you can
move from building to building on campus
so should you need
go eat you have a 10-minute window to
get there then you're locked in again so
you know will you let you go on the comm
and escorted between buildings yes and
you could escape if you want but that
would be a dumb no it's it's what we
call behind the wall so there's this
huge huge wall there's no way okay but
you don't you can you can't save up your
ten minutes and get like an hour you
have ten minutes to walk around ten
minutes and if you're caught then you're
going to the hole hurry for the whole
day except for ten minutes an hour yeah
skip the funky what about lunch do you
you don't get a half an hour first you
get as long as lunch it's an hour and a
half you can sit there for the whole
hour and a half if you choose to that
was a childlike question well you do yes
but it was use a childish question what
do you get for lunch they feed you on a
dollar eighty seven per day you don't
eat well at all
you know how now how do you get
accustomed to it or is it like for the
entire time you're there every meal
you're like this [ __ ] sucks every
meal this sucks that day did you get a
girlfriend in jail cuz women are not
like prison rape thing but they they
they they bond on some level did you
want me your and a half's a while a year
and a half's a while but I'm super
straight so that wasn't happening but
there is the expectation that you're gay
for the stay the minute you walk in the
door so you're walking in they know the
new meat is coming in and they're
watching you from their housing units
picking out who they like so then within
a course of like a week people are
coming up to me like so Davis do you
like girls and I'm like nope nope but
they didn't don't force you or yes no no
no no I like male person do you have to
fight in there though touch with you
know I mean there is a lot of violence
but I think most of its like domestic
violence so girlfriends go in cars where
any of the male guards creepy or no not
totally creepy I saw a number of them
getting walked off for inappropriate
relationships with the women women will
set you up to because they keep your [ __ ]
like it no have you heard they will have
your dance they'll keep your calm in a
[ __ ] whatever they'll spit out and
they have your DNA did you find that
where they were your friends in prison
were they keeping semen no but I knew
girls that were having relationships
with officers for
niceties so makeup and food and things
phones and things that we don't have
access to give him oral sex something
like that yeah right right so when you
first get there
like what's the stretch do you just like
you know what I'm gonna keep to myself
I'm gonna stay in my cell as long as are
my area whatever it is as long as
possible or do you go I'm just gonna do
if I got 10 minutes an hour to walk
around I'm gonna walk around for 10
minutes and try to acclimate myself to
whatever the normal lifestyle is my
strategy I mean my strategy was to find
the food so there's a black market of
underground prison Commerce which is
super cool and interesting and most of
it revolves around food so the people
that work in the kitchen smuggle good
food out and then those of us who don't
work in the kitchen buy it and then we
either resell it or eat it ourselves
because that's the only chance you have
of getting good food and what's good
food eggs like just eggs sugar skulls go
steal the eggs yes yeah and it's like so
the kitchen won't have a ton of eggs no
ton of eggs so it doesn't matter there's
1,100 women on this complex there's
millions of eggs were you able to drink
or get high in there if you do drink or
get I I don't do either of those things
so I did not did you see anybody else
doing them yeah your car lot which was a
lot of pot no I would never I know it's
a joke you're you're a businesswoman yes
and that's I mean you became very very
famous as a Manhattan madam do you do
those instincts start to kick in when
you're in jail like oh my god there's
like do you become somebody who's
reselling a lot of food or whatever the
business that's available to you is um
you know only out of necessity for that
food so in order to make these women who
are coming from the kitchen happy I have
to buy whatever they bring and and then
a lot of that stuff I don't want so I
have to get rid of it but it was mostly
not economic reasons it was like more
dietary your stomach is so messed up but
if you got money going in you could have
money sent to you every month so you
could buy stuff right yeah you can have
money sent to you whenever and but you
have a limit on what you can actually
buy your commissary right yeah yeah
yeah so you never had any problem
getting whatever you wanted in there if
you have a you know no because the big
thing is the food so once you make
friends with everyone and you you know
you control that then everybody's coming
to you to get what they want so what did
you how did you get involved this whole
Mahler grand jury thing Roger stone I
mean Roger stone happens to be one of my
best friends he's my him and his wife
are my child's godparents we do love
Roger I know do you live with Roger in
his duplex Roger lives with me in my
duplex oh you see Roger every day when
he's here in New York when him and mrs.
stoner here I see them every day does he
walk around shirtless he's a very buff
guy I don't know I have a different
business like that it's very buff I was
surprised you never had a sexual
relationship with him no just good
friends
yes passional Roger keeps a professional
so let's let's preface that by I was for
10 years I was senior vice president of
a hedge fund two million dollar fund so
I have a lot of business background
other than being a madam you do yes um
so okay now no so um you meet Roger
you're working with Roger a little bit
and then there's this whole grand jury
investigation that Muller they're
investigating Trump and all that so how
are you called in it just says they just
trying to [ __ ] with Roger I think so I
think so because they didn't ask me
anything
they let me preface that they mostly
were concerned with Russian collusion
which I know nothing about and you know
Roger has a number of tweets that are
for telling so all of these things are
confusing yeah so you know I learned I
was getting subpoenaed on a month
actually I learned that the subpoena
might be coming on Friday I accidentally
talked to a reporter who then went all
over the news talking about having a
conversation with me which I didn't know
she was gonna do then on Monday they
served me and they were pissed that I
spoke to this reporter accidentally how
did you speak to her accidently you're
savvy you know what they want um no
because I've known her for 10 years it
would be like if you called me I've
known you for 10 years if you call me
and were like girl I heard you were
getting subpoenaed
how you feeling and I'm talking to you
as my friend and I think you actually
genuinely care right and then I find out
you're all over the news talking to me
think it's an off-the-record discussion
oh yes so you're not friends with this
person anymore
no no she's been begging for interviews
and I'm she's got the cultural
where's Muller asking you you walk into
the grand jury and there's no lawyer
present right right so let's I mean what
it's like in there is and they're very
big bullies so I learned on Monday I was
getting a subpoena I said I don't have
child care I can't come to DC I'm all
all the way out in California
vacationing with my mom and my
two-year-old son and they're like we
don't care if you can talk to the media
you can figure out how to get to DC we
don't care about any of that stuff on
your kid so they're clearly pissed about
the initial you know they wouldn't make
it hurt all right but I mean how
reasonable is that four days to get
2,500 miles randy Kritika was just
subpoenaed and he got three and a half
weeks so now you're bullying me
Randy's a comical ready to go is a very
liberal comic and he's kind of an
activist back yes you know anything no I
don't yes pictures with Castro credit oh
okay he's very left yeah I mean beyond
but he's been pretty consistent but what
yeah what's his so what's it what's the
deal with him that's it yeah well so
he's the intermediary between Roger
stone and WikiLeaks I thanks friendly
and so there's so opposite critical and
Roger stone are so opposite here's the
background on that they're frenemies
they've been frenemies for many years
right in 2010 I ran Randy critic Oh as a
Senate candidate on my ticket and him
and Roger he ended up heckling me at
some campaign event him and Roger got
into a fistfight I mean but who won
Roger
of course he Rogers yeah I again Rogers
pretty bad ass yeah so but then Randy
got a radio show and he begged Roger and
they became friends again so so they're
intermediary isn't crazy in that world
that what what can make you friends with
somebody and what can it's so awful the
the duplicity and so why don't you look
Randy if him and Roger if you if you ran
him in the new manraja made up on it
you're like um because I'm not the type
to forgive like that I've already
realized he was a douchebag which I said
in front of the grand jury
she said douchebag I certainly did I'm
sure hold my mouth and I'm if I don't
like you you know right away to my don't
like
in your face it was about sorry it's a
bad joke sorry so listen so you're on
the grand jury you walk in you said
they're bullying you know besides being
bullying you and kind of not giving a
[ __ ] and making you get there which is a
little short notice right you walk in
what does the grand jury room like is it
there's obviously a jury but you don't
have an attorney with you you don't have
an attorney so now because they're
bullying me I have to get an attorney
right I have to get a DC attorney so I
choose this amazing attorney Michael
Rosetti he's a partner at Akin Gump and
he's eight hundred and sixty dollars an
hour so now I'm incurring all these
legal fees you go into the every time
you talk on the phone it's like a
half-hour charge you know basically you
go there and you're in this really
nondescript non impressive room with
just the prosecutor who clearly has a
relationship with these jurors because
he's been in there for months
exactly so he's friendly he's cordial
he's laughing making jokes and there's
no defense attorney present for me I
mean it's which is okay because I had
zero criminal liability so I was not
worried about that but in terms of the
way he presented it everything is framed
in a totally negative way to where the
question is almost yes or no and that
things aren't that simple right yes or
no so you know I I personally push back
a lot to where I would try to reframe it
but then I was cut off at times by
hammer the judge right there's no judge
even with my subpoena for four days I
have to tell my first attorney who's not
a DC attorney who I'm like can't we file
a motion with a judge to get more time
this is unacceptable I'm going to lose a
lot of money on vacation blah blah blah
he's like there is no judge you can't do
that and that that motion would have to
be filed with the overall of DC federal
court and that motion would cost like 10
grand so if you do that let's say you go
and there's the prosecutor and you want
to like he wants a yes or no answer but
you want to give it who has the right to
stop you if you're like no I'm gonna
answer no question no way across I mean
if he's coming out with a question you
you should have somebody there to
rebuttal his question right not allowed
it's a secret jury it's a seizure injury
what's wrong no it's good one to
rebuttal his thing yes
yeah and no you can't take the fifth on
any of this stuff you say I could I
could but but then the thing is they've
already given you what's called a
proffer so anything you say in there it
can't be used against you so if you
plead the fifth they're just gonna go
and get a judge to then order you to
answer the question because they've
given you immunity so you're really not
incriminating so you aren't scared for
yourself no not at all they asking you
about Roger Oh like his Podesta tweet
told you no where did he get those did
he have you no knowledge and I'm like
dude is amazing and had Julian Assange
on in June 2016 two months before the
tweet you know and and so he definitely
could have gotten this all from outside
sources is it amazing like that the
power like the tweets have yeah it
should be start like these innocuous
like who cares things are now the
conversation in a grand jury room well
and everybody's taken that tweet right
and ripped it apart because he said the
Podesta's with an s not the Podesta but
the media has taken the the and the s
off as if to make him appear worse and
that's sort of like what concerned me
going in there is that they're sitting
here and they're using like get me Roger
stone which tells of this almac ominous
ominous I can't talk today
dominus that's what I meant loss is
contagious yeah so it's it's foretelling
of this like ominous guy and all these
different things and that's not really
who he is as a person do you think Roger
is nervous about this oh sure especially
after yesterday man why ft-lb cuz if not
afford a man if I go go why are you deep
does it are you nervous
in any way because I mean especially
after your experience of okay like I'm
sure that you never thought you would
end up in jail you ended up in jail and
now this is somehow in your lap right
even just be a part of it does it freak
you out a little bit especially because
when I went on CNN Chris Cuomo this
hasn't really come out they were very
upset with that performance who's they
the prosecutors huh why and just because
I spoke badly about them first of all I
think they said that they would cover
all travel expenses they didn't do that
I incurred $1,400 worth of fees even
they booked my rooms and said oh this is
on
cart nope it wasn't they didn't they
left me stranded in DC with no return
ticket back there were numerous
different things they did to to bully me
and push my buttons and I talked about
it on CNN and good day New York and they
got mad and they called my attorney and
they were trying to find some ridiculous
reason to recall me just to bust my
balls again and bully me and that at
that time I said you know what bring it
on I'm ready so I want to recall me
bring me back in because I don't I
haven't perjured myself and now it's
bullying and I'm and I was even
respectful I went in with no fanfare
through the back entrance I didn't want
the press but now I'm going in the front
and I'm gonna say what I think of you so
now you you Muller was the guy actually
asking you the questions no it was a
different attorney it was a different
attorney okay they PI of someone doing
certain people and right guys doing it's
like it's a second unit when you shoot a
film cuz I'm gonna say for the record I
know a lot about this collusion thing so
but if they want to bring me to DC they
have to fly me first class and put me up
in a good hotel but you do know a lot
about collusion I have I happen to know
a lot about you're talking about and how
long have a stay in a hotel tonight
should be nice so I you better not call
me do you think do you what do you think
the likelihood is that Roger stone ends
up in jail because I think you know the
likelihood that you know manna fort and
Michael Cohen do at least sometime it's
pretty likely at this point may probably
not these maximum sense and says that
everybody's calm and forth they said
wants no time because he's older he's
like [ __ ] a convicted of eight counts
and then 10 of them were like a hung
jury so that's not good for him no no
but you don't have much discretion in
the federal sentencing system there's a
guidelines
all right so 80 percent or some [ __ ] you
gotta do it's based on the level of your
crime and all these other hating they
can't be pardoned they can trump apart
anybody better make Trump look extremely
bad make you look terrible right he
could do it like maybe before he went
out of office at the end right at the
very end he could probably do it
immediately he wanted and he wouldn't
get relied that would be the thing that
certainly would not I don't know I don't
think he wants to be reelected you know
back in all this nonsense torn his
family apart he's not making as much
money as he should
like his pat on the ego though to be the
president that's true well Roger that
read the president
like Roger yes they know each other yeah
no no do you think Roger stone ends up
in jail I not not should he but just
based on in this experience of the
system do you think what do you think
the likelihood is that he will end up in
jail because of all this not saying he's
guilty but just saying that you know how
this with the way this thing is being
setup as much as it breaks my heart to
say I think it's likely that he'll get
some sort of charges and they'll
probably they're not going to be for
rush inclusion because that didn't
happen but I mean it's gonna be a mana
for type thing where they're just
looking for something and you know and
and they're gonna find it if you're
looking for something you will always
find it what do you think if it's not a
hundred percent real you'll create it
into what you want it to be what do they
want from Roger what do you think they
want from him
well I think they definitely want to pin
him to some sort of collusion that's
really what they're interested in and I
think in the climate today they have to
they can't bring any more of these tax
charges without tacking something
related to the 2016 election in there so
do you think that they're just trying to
get Roger to talk about Trump but they
don't really want Roger they want Trump
so they weren't they will talk to try to
get Roger to flip on Trump yes yes
Rogers probably not gonna Rogers not
gonna flip right and that's why he's
gonna end up doing something correct
getting some kind of charge probably
right because they want Trump in the
they have to go after everyone around
him just like they called me they're
going after everybody around Roger
satellites around around the satellites
around the moons to get my planet doing
right is Roger dealing with that
mentally like okay there's a real
possibility that I end up being charged
with something doing some time on this
is he kind of aware that this could be
his fate well he wouldn't be Roger stone
if he didn't have a strategy right so he
is all on top of that he's got a
numerous attorneys he has a plan he is
very well prepared for whatever has he
picked your brain about about jail so he
kind of has a sense of what it's like I
have volunteered my expertise okay a
fortune with all the [ __ ] lawyers
millions millions of dollars for
attorneys my attorney for those two for
two visits and just some phone calls has
been like 20 yeah it's amazing amazing
the government can put you through that
whether or not you know especially you
didn't do
anything and then you have to get a
lawyer they don't pay you back back for
that and if you're not guilty they don't
pay your attorney mm-hmm and it's not
even like like Kristen is just
associated with somebody else that
they're trying to get it's not even
about you've done anything so now it's
like guilty by association just because
your friends were here that you now have
to incur $20,000 worth of fees for being
your friend
absolutely and I say for the record I
know what's going on all this Busa for
business I know you know goose I won't
say unless they send me to a first class
at a nice hotel for two nights of DC
with a fine meal and to me and leave you
with no return flight and then you had
to get a five hundred and fifty dollar
ticket to get home oh you can pack club
soda Kenny would you mr. Muller you take
pawn this accommodation they would Kenny
would get that [ __ ] money now how
does that happen do they tell you like
okay here's your flight information you
get to DC you're there and you find out
that this information they gave you is
not accurate or did they tell you we'll
let you know what the return flight is
once you get there or you find out you
you don't have a way to get home the
government has a travel office they give
you an itinerary so then you know they
told me it was an open-ended ticket with
no return on the I think they need you
more than one day oh well in case it
lasted longer the meeting sure a grand
jury oh and they did change my time so
it was an acceptable answer and I got to
the airport and I gave them the number
and they're like no there's no ticket
right and then do you call somebody and
say like or is there nobody to call
there's nobody to call right I'd have to
call I don't have their number directly
sure I'd have to call my attorney to
then call and my attorney was actually
with me he escorted me to you know to
the airlines and we had nothing they fly
you first-class it would be no Jim
Norton and the [ __ ] hearing so
they won't get the Gusev our information
that you have you want gusta fur you
want ass and perhaps I can provide those
things but not for [ __ ] economy first
class has to be only first class they
have a very good rate on the shuttle
though my five hundred and fifty dollars
ticket was fifty one dollars Oh
fifty bucks not bad so they skipped out
on a fifty dollar return ticket so that
you could pay five fifty I know
efficient the government amazing and
they're gonna have to pay it
so it's just kind of silly did they
offer to pay you back for your flight
they did but that was a couple weeks ago
now and we still don't have any money or
a voucher so the way they work is they
give they approved the charges they give
you a voucher and then you have to
submit the voucher to the government all
right first it so I'm still probably a
month away from maybe getting
reimbursement and I'm you know opening a
business on Friday
what kind of business it's a nail art
boutique no Beauty lab calm that by the
way this our smart Kristen is right as
soon as she got here she was like yeah
my nails look nice hi Jen
yeah she didn't mention that earlier
last time I was here Judy gold was here
and she was like those are hooker nails
and I'm like yeah well I used to be a
madam did you ever hook her no no you
know that I don't remember the answer
come on my memory stinks I mean I would
knock it if you know no you were just
you were just kind of the brains all
right do you think part of this is
because of the politicians that were
associated with your former business and
people trying to get back to you maybe
you've made some enemies in Washington
I've certainly made some enemies right
but it has nothing to do no friends away
about oh I certainly I have a lot of I
mean a lot of politicians supported my
candidacy they're gonna support my
future candidacy Joe Senator Joe Bruno
the mayor of Watertown New York a lot of
people in New York were supportive of
you gonna run for governor again no but
I will probably run for Senate I feel
like if I had lived the life that you've
lived the last thing I would want to do
was anything public just like let me go
jump in a hole and like just leave me
alone for after this but then you also
have to consider like I feel like I've
been bullied by the government I feel
like I've seen the other side where
these guys can do whatever they want to
people who don't have any power and
aren't using their voice so I want to be
the one in there calling everybody out
on all the nonsense they're doing
because I'll be honest I remember I was
invited to be your lieutenant governor I
remember you asked me that now I didn't
do it to my managers to know and I'll do
it you're comedian you gotta just be -
all right I didn't do it but it was it
was very nice imitation I've never been
invited into politics no I would
probably what was the dinner maybe it
was del Frisco's did it might have been
I think he'd be a great politician I
mean why you're very open-minded yeah
but I mean I am open-minded
yes you're right maybe I would be I
should get involved the enemies you
occurred I mean these people came for
your service it's not your [ __ ] fault
you know why would they turn on you if
they're coming because they're afraid
that I was going to release their names
and credit card imprints so that there
was a lot of anger but I never did that
yeah let me know if you know if you
didn't snitch and make sure what the
[ __ ] that should be they should be
contributing to my legal fees yeah
that's right [ __ ] on your team you
saved them yes I you know you took a
fall for these [ __ ] [ __ ] she just
said it would have did this isn't what
it was about them you should also know
about the other people that turned on
her huh yeah before so after you did
after so people have kind of let go of
that and now this is about your
relationship with Roger stone pretty
much exclusively correct well I've
worked for Roger stone off and on for
ten years so I worked Gary Johnson's
presidential campaign I didn't work
Trump's but I have worked on a lot of
campaigns for him and a lot of things
you didn't vote for Trump correct no so
this is amazing that like you got
wrapped up in all this Trump stuff and
you're like I have I didn't even vote
for the guy I mean I wasn't a super
supporter I supported Gary Johnson the
president you know I I regret that as
well when you when you when you were as
a supporter of Gary Johnson when he was
asked to start naming other countries
and things like that and he couldn't do
it were you going like Oh Gary oh no
yeah sometimes when you're on the
spotlight it's hard you know it's hard
to get the answer out if you're thinking
of something else and you're nervous but
if you want to be the president that
should be good at say naming foreign
leaders should be a skilled speaker like
Roger stone who is an excellent speaker
Roger stone is a great Ducker and Dodger
and I'm not even knocking him I'm saying
like he knows how to like eel throats of
the army he knows how to duck and then
reframe it into what he wants to say
about it do you think Rogers done shady
[ __ ] define shady
well things that maybe not quite on the
up-and-up do you think there's things
about Roger stone that people don't know
or do you think its villainous
reputation is not as accurate as people
think it is I think Roger doesn't break
crimes doesn't commit crimes I should
say
and so but I think he he does a lot of
dirty tricks you know and so there's the
borderline of what is legal and what's
not legal and I think he always walks on
the side that's legal
like he's but he's very aware of what
these laws are he stages riots and he
does all of these things and he knows
what he stays riots you know that I
can't even talk Brooks Brothers riots
for George Bush okay so that's a
well-known thing that he's done you know
he orchestrates all of these things to
get people in office or to fulfill an
agenda and he consults his attorneys
before he do you think he has a lot of
connections oh my gosh so many
connections Roger stone is like
ridiculous yeah he they when you're
sitting there hanging out with Roger
stone and just talking to him he doesn't
get to this place where he's like you
know what I don't want to do all this
political nonsense anymore this is
exhausting no he loves it
that's amazing I'm streaming around he's
talking to Trump does he ask you to
leave the room or is he just like Shh um
I usually leave out of respect you want
to hear those conversations I'm like the
least nosy person you've ever met what I
want to know anybody's personal business
it doesn't not even be nosy but if
you're in the room and he's talking
about the president will he will he will
he talk different when you're there or
just go like hey he'll just go hey he
doesn't care if I'm there way at this
point - I mean you'd rather not have the
information just because little
information you have as possible is
probably better for you that's right
yeah you don't want to know I don't know
all you want to do is make some make
people's fingernails look pretty that's
right I just want to do something that's
sparkly and happy that doesn't make me
think too hard and doesn't land me in
jail
and how did jail affect you like
obviously you know I read something
about PTSD and what's all that was is
that for is that for for jail just for
when you're in Rikers I definitely had
it in Rikers because being in solitary
is awful and that's the worst prison in
the world it's disgusting regular prison
was not that bad honestly I was planning
for my release from the day that I got
in there so I was ready to hit the
ground running it's like we say you only
do two days the day you go in and the
day your first day in your last day
who's we
convicts hardened people men in the
street I see what that street cred
I do yeah you know man who've seen it
all that you had you met Remy Ma while
you were there I did a Metro me
Ryker's oh wow did you help her write
her diss track of Nicki Minaj she's you
know what she is one of the most
amazingly smart people I have ever met
her use of the English knowledge the
dictionary is ridiculous so we play
Scrabble and like I'm over here with dog
dogs she's got some like crazy word and
I'm like that's not even a word the
dictionary bodied Bo di D it's just like
I'm like I don't even I've never even
heard that word yeah do you stay friends
with her after Rikers we stayed friends
for a couple of years I used to visit
her in Bedford Hills and then over the
years we lost touch okay I just kind of
naturally yeah well I was on probation I
wasn't supposed to go see her and I
risked it all to go see her many times
and bring her food for packages for her
commissary and then I just my probation
officers was like hey you can't do this
Phil Selman helped a lot of people on
the way up Chris Rock Adam those guys
none of them talk to him anymore
no they they don't help Phil anymore
they don't show it right where's yours
I'm grateful I'm grateful talking bad
about me before I come here
he did really not a lot of good things
you could say about you what about you
you can't even you can't even say it
properly I've raised three kids I have
32 years sober right there that's enough
to talk about Thank You Phil comment
what do you didn't clean for 15 years
you're not clean I'm your smoke pot
that's clean I hate what you were going
cleaning they smoke pot how many people
are in federal prison for marijuana
that's ridiculous that's crazy
in in states where it's legal in
California that's where I did my time
but ten years no federal federal laws
that marijuana's illegal state's laws
that it's not but if you're in federal
prison they don't care what the state
law is yes sir do people get busted in
California under federal charges yes how
do you like so the Fed however why
investigating some drug cartel and
there's marijuana and it's marijuana
then they just go arrest you and now
you're in federal prison in California
for something that's legal in the state
just because they want to get you for
something
so that's correct we can that's a
federal crime we can get you for that so
we're gonna lie most government
investigations revolve around money so
they're investigating you because they
want your money so it's it's a it's an
industry so how come they haven't called
Roger like if they've called you and
they've called so many of the people why
do you think they haven't got him well
most of the time when there's a secret
grand jury proceeding they don't call
the person that they're interested in
trying to get information first to and
get off I think this is just gonna
indict you in secret and come and arrest
you
this has just happened to me in 2008 I
was arrested in a secret grand jury
indictment with 240 pages and I never
actually knew what evidence they had
against me because I didn't have the
money to fight that case wait do you
have to go and there's a secret
indictment do they don't call you to
testify your own thing or no no no the
whole point is to get an indictment
against you and arrest you they don't
care what you know they've already
determined in their heads that you're
guilty of this so they're not giving you
a chance to defend yourself so they're
certainly not going to invite you in and
let you ruin their case you got to get
enough proof it's like a warrant you
can't get a warrant without enough proof
right and you can't get an indictment
but this is already an indictment as
soon as that sucker sealed they're
coming with the handcuffs and you're
right yeah I'd be very nervous if I was
Roger stone in fact that all this is
going on and nothing has happened to him
I don't think that that means they don't
have anything I think it means that he's
the one they're trying to build the case
against maybe yeah it might be I mean
that's it yes if they if they weren't
trying to build a case against him
they'd be using him or at least trying
to use him to build the case against
somebody they still may do that but they
may want to they may want to get
everybody around him first then they
start going after the bigger yeah why do
you suppose Roger is the guy do you
think it's because they think he's would
be the hardest to turn do you think
because you know they got knows the most
they got the former lawyer they got
Rogers his notorious reputation so if
anyone out of the manna manna for and
stone and all these other characters I
mean they got the manna for it in the
manna fort in stone right yeah yeah so
if anybody in the Trump campaign who
would actually be the one to have
colluded probably the one with the worst
reputation and the re Roger I see so
they might be holding out to go after
him I think are you know like he'll turn
probably when they probably don't think
he'll turn either which is why they're
like instead of threatening him with
this and that since he won't buckle
right let's get everybody else to turn
on him collect the evidence
and then bust him for whether he admits
it or not yeah that is probably the
strategy do you think that my hypothesis
could be true it could be it could be
who are they calling it right after you
who right before you do you know well
Andrew Miller who was my 2010 campaign
manager right so Roger was my strategist
Andrew was my manager and Andrews
fighting his subpoena so he recently
just lost but he's appealing that so
he's fighting it on the grounds of
whether or not the special counsels
office is a valid office man and you ran
for what professor of New York New York
City Comptroller also so you ran you you
you've run for election before it once
you went in front of the grand jury is
that when your view of the United States
government like had a whole different
perspective meaning like is that when
you really started to figure out how
things worked or did you have a pretty
good idea I did have 40 good idea in
2008 after getting arrested yeah so but
this was this was eye-opening I'm not
gonna lie this was eye-opening I mean
obviously it's a little bit scary going
into a grand jury someone with felonies
and having to be back in a federal
courtroom is horrible no you have
immunity has got to be nice it's it's
it's it's okay I mean there's no I had
no liability so it really even didn't
bother me but but seeing how the system
works from that side being actually in
the secret grand jury and seeing it not
being the one victimized by it but
actually being there and seeing it was
horrible I don't understand how justice
can ever be done because whatever they
will find will be something that has
been somewhat manufactured on the
narrative that they're feeding and so us
the American people will never really
have a clear answer well it's kind of
like what Roger stone does in terms of I
know exactly what the laws are so I know
exactly what I can get away with so
that's what I'm gonna do it seems like
when the government wants to take
somebody down they go okay I know
constitutionally what I can do I know
how to build a case so we're going to
we're not gonna go against the
Constitution we're not gonna do anything
we can't but we're gonna use every
single power they know how to have you
yes they know how to [ __ ] you and they
know how to make you spend money and
they have a lot of power today it's not
their money right so they can ask you to
do anything
our money it's our money but they but
you have to pay for a lawyer so they can
ask you do this do that and file motions
and then your attorney has to respond
and then they keep delaying it and you
have to keep paying your attorney and it
becomes this [ __ ] endless thing right
well I think what people don't realize
is like 97% of federal cases plead out
why is that because it's expensive to
fight your case and then there's also
the sentencing guidelines which means
that you're not going to get a deal if
you take your case to trial so they're
banking on that they're having a secret
grand jury right now if they indict him
they're almost banking on the fact that
he won't be able to come up with the
money or take the risk to fight it so he
may never know what's involved in there
obviously Roger stone is willing to take
the risk and he's gonna find the money
so he's gonna fight it so thank you
enemy I'll find the money oh he'll find
the money we need their worst enemy when
you got arrested what did you cope with
the idea that okay I might actually be
found guilty here I might actually be
going to jail or did you kind of believe
that'll never happen to me I don't think
this is gonna happen like did you did
you were you ready um I was ready in
2008 I went former Governor Eliot
Spitzer was caught with a girl I knew
there were plenty of wire transfers to
my bank account from him there was a
trail of money and and since they had
been investigating him I'm quite sure I
was involved somehow so I look lawyer
DUP prior what was that I'm sorry okay
was it maddening to you when you're you
know on trial and end up in jail and he
ends up with a TV show out of the deal
yes of course that's why I ran for
governor as a protest candidate because
I was extremely pissed people are like
don't you feel sorry for him what do you
mean he got a two million dollar CNN
deal or whatever that was right I feel
sorry for myself though the state took
all of my money but he's the one who got
to [ __ ] the prostitute what but the big
issue is that in 2007 when one of his
first acts as governor was to change the
law right it was a misdemeanor for a man
getting caught with a prostitute he made
it a felony
so that was my big thing is like how is
it okay that this man who changed the
law to make it a felony to get caught
with a prostitute is not being
prosecuted under the old law that he
created right so here I am like losing
everything
and this guy is like gets a get out of
jail free training it's pretty cool
documentary about when you when yes yes
when I mean do you lose property and
there's all of my bank accounts all my
safety deposit accounts accounts in
other people's name they knew where
every day and they get to safety deposit
box they can get everything really it h
everything everything the [ __ ]
what did you have in your safety deposit
box - boss don't make fun of Jim frsky
stupid coin she just said safety deposit
boxes and then you went because they get
to your safety deposit boxes so they
made me wire transfer it back in and
another thing too and this is back when
they say immunity is that across the
board or can they come up with something
else ago this has is not related its sub
related and you don't have it's really
not they give you immunity for what you
say however if they're able to
investigate those things and find any
other additional crime you are not given
immunity sub crimes in the federal
system it's called relevant conduct so
ok this action was relevant to this
action what if you live they catch you
lying that's perjury but you know
whatever then they can and then that
will you lose your immunity but if you
don't give us everything you know that
could be even you don't lie lie but even
if you lie by omission or just don't you
know like Kristen said you can't plead
the fifth yeah because there's no judge
right so you don't say anything mmunity
watch some turkey bacon
but you didn't I thought you know the
Fosters question was good turkey bacon
why is he keep pushing the turkey baby's
got
go to waste if if someone's hungry
there's turkey baking you [ __ ]
[ __ ] whoa that was a standard
question turkey bacon now I know why
nobody will [ __ ] help you I help
you're a nobody
what was your what was your friendship
and that which made me speaking you know
if phil was in here talking about how
you know all the people he's helped you
know they ignore him now bosses he's
made a habit of losing friends as the
years go by a minute that's right what
was your network of friends like when
you got out of jail everything's done
time to rebuild your life did you have
the same people there waiting for you
did you have a rude awakening about
people associating with you rude
awakening I had no friends and my
boyfriend at the time who I lived with
out went out and got credit cards under
my name and charging up $100,000 worth
of bills in four months what do you buy
he was partying bottles girls probably I
don't know yeah and while you're in jail
super mad Wow how could he use how could
you do it on under the computer and
logged in as me and because he's got all
your passwords in there because you have
to be there yeah you trying to get my
[ __ ] wife passwords your wife you'd
still be responsible for the debt yeah
you're married my wife's dead is your
tenth yeah that would be really shooting
yourself in the foot
[Laughter]
stupid yeah some time yeah so you sued
him though I sued him and you win
I got a settlement okay all right it was
pennies pennies no friendship no way you
married no no way no so it's on your
it's on your ring finger
I meant hitting on you so you right did
it there are people away no no what is
your friend like now I don't have a boy
why not
by the way too much work oh that's a
very smooth way to ask that question Jim
I like yeah Chris is my friend I know
but your game I've never hit on Chris
your game is tight though when you're
like oh what's your boyfriend dude
that's like the way you know because
Jimmy owes me like brunch from a million
years ago that you never followed Jim
I'm busy you're naked
your characters are insulting you yeah
[Laughter]
very [ __ ] intrigued by her that's
very nice
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
which is the lowest class you live all
right on my couch and i mattr stay in a
hotel tell me this tell me I think do
you think the reason that rich is now
going back on the joke you made is
because clearly we like Kristen clearly
his joke bomb he wants to be accepted in
the room but I'm intrigued specially
prison stories listen I like a pretty
story tonight I'll be doing a drag part
on their plane which is mother my son
the drug he's dead Kristen you don't
have to deal with this in your day to
day do you I mean this is ridiculous no
you my first London my first real radio
you enjoy the experience of course yeah
I enjoy Phil very much I was happy you
contacted me him please me please please
by Jim Norton boss the juries at now oh
I'm sorry
now I'll try to give you something I'll
try to help you were there people
Kristen when you were in 2008 2007
leading up to that whole all that drama
were there people that we and I'm not
gonna ask you to name names clearly but
were there people reaching out to you
worried sure after the Spitzer thing
happened that you were gonna reveal more
names because I'm sure that you had more
yes sure was not I mean my client list
was 10,000 names I kept all their credit
card imprints I mean I've done a lot of
things where people worried that they
were like you can't there was a lot of
death threats but I'm really something
my nature to right niche on somebody
where I need them legit like which I
mean a lot of people you know say dumb
ship was there anybody who threatened
you and you're like yeah it's a
legitimate threat yeah there were a few
yeah I was a little concerned but I mean
that's not I I knew in time that would
all discipline when they show you know
yes Larry Flynt offered me like a
million dollars to buy my client list
when I called my attorney and I was like
so I got this offer and all my money's
gone what should I do
and my attorneys say you know I think
you should listen to the nicest and most
the voice of reason your mother because
he knows my mother well and so I called
her and she said let me think about it
and then the next day she called me back
and she said you know you're gonna
destroy families and ruin people who
their children their wives their the
innocence and that do you really want
that on your shoulders and I'm like the
money would be spent and you'd have them
all gunning for you yeah so I I didn't I
decline that don't need me a cool [ __ ]
you'd end up spending all the money on
legal fees and stuff and yes still have
a whole bunch of enemies and it's like
what what for what do you get $400,000
what you do a California madam that
turned state's evidence the high place
nowhere it's actually one of my friends
ideas off those are all my buddies you
know feather yeah